Netflix's Wednesday was built on the
back of two iconic 90s Adams Family
movies but it's a lot more than just a
rehash of those classic comedies here's
all the ways the streaming hit changes
course Wednesday the new Creepy and
kooky Netflix series takes a closer and
arguably overdue look at Wednesday Adams
a character who has long been a fan
favorite in a Netflix series Wednesday
goes from being merely a supporting
character to the main protagonist
although plenty of people are eager to
see what Netflix's Wednesday has in
store it has a lot to live up to the
berry sun and felt films of the early
90s were a big part of many Millennial
childhoods so fans of The Addams Family
franchise are hoping for something new
and compelling while also maintaining
the spirit and fun of The Originals of
course Wednesday is not a carbon copy of
the Sun and felt movies but even so be
advised this is a major spoiler alert so
consider this your final warning while
Christina Ricci did a lot to make
Wednesday a memorable character in the
1991 and 1993 Addams Family movies she
was not the sole focus of the films the
plot of the first film The Adams Family
centered around the supposed return of
Gomez's long-lost brother fester in the
film a pair of wicked schemers Abigail
Kramer and her son Gordon planned to con
the unsuspecting atoms into believing
that Gordon who Bears an uncanny
resemblance to the missing Fester is
actually the real deal although
Wednesday and Pugsley are not the focus
of the plot their characters are Central
to the final Revelation that Gordon is
indeed fester and reuniting the family
with their electrifying Uncle the sequel
to The Adams Family is set two years
later with Gomez and Morticia welcoming
their newest little monster a Sunday
whimsically named pubert once again the
unsuspecting atoms hire a scheming nanny
who plans to seduce and marry Uncle
Fester in order to gain control of the
family fortune when Wednesday becomes
suspicious of her motives Nanny Debbie
convinces Morticia and Gomez to send the
two older siblings to summer camp forced
to endure swimming lessons in the
pristine Lake and moonlit evenings
huddled around a campfire singing
endless rounds of Kumbaya Wednesday
finally gets a chance to mope in the
spotlight biting her time until she
takes her revenge in Epic fashion
[Music]
it isn't however until the new Netflix
series Wednesday that the Adams family's
deadpan Diva finally gets the full
attention she deserves played by Jenna
Ortega best known for portraying the
role of Harley in the Disney Channel's
Stuck in the Middle Wednesday is no
longer the little girl from the movies
now 15 she has wilted into an angsty
Gothic teenager who has been expelled
from her public high school for taking
particularly gruesome revenge on some
school bullies enrolled in her parents
old alma mater Nevermore Academy
Wednesday is forced to contend with a
bubbly roommate a suspicious principal
and a murder mystery threatening not
only the lives of her fellow students
but her entire family
one notable difference between the
Netflix series and The Addams Family
movies is that in the Netflix show we
discovered that Wednesday has developed
psychic powers though there is no
explicit mention of Wednesday having
psychic Visions in The Addams Family
movies there were hints she might have
some kind of Supernatural ability
perhaps sensing that something was amiss
even if she couldn't put her finger on
precisely what in the series we learn
Wednesday's Visions started just a few
months before arriving at Nevermore and
her mother gives her an amulet that also
seems to trigger something in her the
Visions reveal both the past and the
future and center around her ancestor
goody Adams as well as the violent
attacks of a strange monster that stalks
the school grounds you were the key
Wednesday Adams may have a sadistic
streak but she also has a creative side
in The Addams Family movies Wednesday's
Hobbies mainly include torturing her
brother Pugsley and baby pubert and she
can get pretty imaginative with it too
it takes an inventive mind to shake
things up in a torture chamber after all
away at boarding school however without
access to her go-to torture tools from
home Wednesday uses a typewriter as a
creative Outlet instead devoting an hour
every day to writing her novel we see
her hard at work at it throughout the
series taking inspiration for characters
and plot from her own real-life murder
investigation we learned that Wednesday
has actually written three novels all
starring a teenage girl detective named
Viper de la muerte who is smart
perceptive and chronically misunderstood
it's no accident perhaps that her
heroine sounds suspiciously like someone
we know sadly Wednesdays gratuitously
morbid subject matter keeps her work
from getting published although
Wednesday Adams is 15 years old in the
Netflix series it soon becomes apparent
that she hasn't had much time for
romance after all regular relationships
are enough of a challenge for someone
with her socially awkward disposition
yet in Wednesday she finds herself with
two young men who are both attracted to
her and competing for her attention the
first is Xavier Thorpe a fellow student
at Nevermore with both magical and
artistic talents and Tyler Galpin son of
the local sheriff and a normie at first
Wednesday deduces that the murderous
hide monster stalking the town and
Nevermore is Xavier however she later
realizes she has made a grave error
after sharing a kiss with Tyler that
triggers a vision
of course the first boy I kiss would
turn out to be a psychotic serial
killing monster
this is Wednesday's first kiss in the
series happens very differently than in
the movie Adam's Family Values
Wednesday's first kiss is a sweet Peck
through a chain-link fence while in the
series it is definitely much more
passionate
the movies Wednesday never seemed to be
inclined toward music Still she did
exhibit a leaning toward the theater as
seen in The Adams Family when she and
Pugsley perform a dramatic Shakespearean
scene together at the school talent show
thanks to some help from Uncle Fester
the Adam's siblings managed to leave the
audience speechless and drenched in
stage blood in the series however
Wednesday turns her artistic interests
to creative writing and playing the
cello and has become a masterful
musician the show actually treats us to
two memorable performances the first and
instrumental rendition of painted black
which Wednesday plays on the balcony
outside her dorm room as well as a
jaunty rendition of Fleetwood Macs don't
stop which she plays as a statue of town
founder Joseph crackstone Goes Up in
Flames though she may not show emotions
in her day-to-day routines Wednesday's
passion clearly comes out as she plays
the cello and it's a change from the
original movies that helps give more
Dimension to her character
for more than 30 years The Adams Family
consisted of Gomez Morticia Pugsley
Wednesday Uncle Fester and Granny of
course Singh and Lurch are also like
family but let's stick to immediate
blood relations for the moment in the
original movie The Adams Family Morticia
reveals to her beloved Gomez that they
are about to welcome a new addition to
the family and the 1993 sequel Adams
Family Values begins with Morticia
giving birth to baby pubert though the
Wednesday series includes iconic Addams
Family characters such as thing Lurch
Gomez Morticia and fester pubert has
been left out altogether it seems that
while the show's creators have drawn on
a few elements of the Sun and felt
movies it was decided to stick with the
original family lineup from The New
Yorker cartoon while The Addams Family
movies are examples of the Classic Fish
Out of Water story compared to the world
around them the atomses are strange
spooky and even at times borderline
psychotic it's their attempts to
interact with normal people that make
for the most hilarious moments in the
Sun and felt films you are too precious
but words why I could just eat you alive
oh no Margaret too young however despite
their eccentricities the atomses are
still mostly human while the family
might be creepy the original Adams
Family films never really took a full
plunge into the realm of the
supernatural all of that changes in
Wednesday though the students of
Nevermore Academy are called outcasts
but the school offers a safe space for
Sirens werewolves Gorgons vampires and
the just plain weird to be themselves
there is also a murderous creature known
as a hide haunting the woods whose
identity is a mystery until Wednesday
takes the case other paranormal elements
including Wednesday's visions and a
connection with her ghostly ancestor
goody Adams feel organic even if none of
the preceding films went in that
direction
the original Addams Family films clearly
fall into the comedy genre with plenty
of dark humor accompanying the family's
zany Antics and hilarious Shenanigans
and the tone is generally light most of
the violence in the movies is either
implied or happens off screen with even
the darkest moments carried out in an
almost Looney Tunes type style the
Wednesday series on Netflix on the other
hand is not afraid to go all in and does
not shy away from displaying a more
gruesome and horror-fueled Tableau the
murder and Mayhem are far from implied
and we get to see some of it up close
and personal the added murder mystery
element in Wednesday also allows room
for the series to Branch out the deeper
her investigation goes the more danger
Wednesday finds herself in as she her
friends and her family members become
targets for the killer the ghosts demons
and bloodthirsty creatures are very real
and the lives of everyone at Nevermore
hang in the balance
although the Wednesday series goes
deeper into the bond between the two
siblings in The Addams Family movies
brother and sister Pugsley and Wednesday
are quite the dynamic duo Wednesday is
the leader of the two and Pugsley is
more than happy to go along with
whatever she has planned whether he is
the victim of her sadistic devices or
assisting her with getting rid of their
baby brother Pugsley is her willing
sidekick it's a tradition one of us has
to go
which one well they only need one boy
it's rarely apparent why Pugsley is so
amenable to Wednesday's methods in the
90s films is it purely his mischievous
nature or perhaps an innate
sadomasochistic streak the relationship
between them is left ambiguous so it's
difficult to tell whether the two hate
or love one another or if they feel any
emotion towards each other at all
Netflix's Wednesday gives a bit more
clarity to the relationship between the
Adam's siblings first in the series it's
established that Wednesday is older than
Pugsley and Pugsley is less of a
Mischief maker and more of a somewhat
dim but sensitive Soul a fault Wednesday
criticizes him for calling showing
emotion a sign of weakness it's also
made apparent that Pugsley has a great
deal of affection for his sister and
that Wednesday is very protective of her
little brother this is a close practice
the only person
torture my brother is me by the end of
the series though Wednesday's Chile
personality has thawed somewhat and her
experiences have perhaps warmed her just
enough to release her Ironclad control
over her emotions at least temporarily
although it seems unlikely that she will
ever give up on viewing her life through
a darker lens Wednesday does appear to
be opening up a bit to the possibilities
offered by her new life at Nevermore
Academy New Friends a new cell phone and
her very first stalker all look like
they might be in her future if only she
would take a chance and send her first
text a new chapter also seems to be
opening on The Adams Family Home Front
when Wednesday finally decides to
confide in her mother that she has
violent dark visions and is afraid
because she can't control them for the
first time Morticia offers her daughter
some advice one Seer to another and a
new stronger Bond of trust and respect
is forged between mother and daughter
built on a better understanding of their
different natures and approaches to life
the show does seem to lay the groundwork
for future Adventures Wednesday is
growing up and who knows it might be
possible that even sibling rivalry could
be cast aside and she might One Day
begin to express a little bit of
fondness for Pugsley don't push it